♪ ♪
>> Greg: OH, MY HEAD.
THE NEW STUDY FOUND THAT AMONG
CAMPUS ADMINISTRATORS, LIBERALS
OUTNUMBER CONSERVATIVES BY 12-1.
>> [BOOING]
>> Greg: TO PUT IT IN
PERSPECTIVE, NORTH KOREA HAS
MORE DIVERSITY.
THE RESULT IS A STUDENT BODY
GOING DEEPER INTO DEBT AND ONLY
EXPOSED ONE KIND OF THINKING,
THE KIND THAT MAKES KIDS DUMBER,
SO THEY DON'T NOTICE IT'S ALSO
MAKING THEM BROKE.
LET'S TRY SOME COLLEGE-LEVEL
MATH.
THE NUMBER OF COLLEGE AND THE
TRADERS HAS DOUBLED IN THE LAST
25 YEARS.
THE ONLY THING GROWING FASTER IS
JESSE'S HAIR.
>> Dana: [LAUGHS]
>> Greg: IT'S HIS REAL HAIR,
BY THE WAY.
STUDENT DEBT NOW TOPS
$1.5 TRILLION.
THAT'S 37 GRAND PER KID.
WHAT DO YOU GET FOR THAT?
A STUPIDITY FARM KEPT AFLOAT ON
THE BACKS OF STUDENTS AND THEIR
PARENTS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT LEARNING
ANYTHING OF PRACTICAL VALUE,
IT'S TRUE, STUDENTS WON'T
REALIZE IT.
$1.5 TRILLION.
IT'S BASICALLY OUR OWN
VENEZUELA, A THIRD WORLD
SOCIALIST SINKHOLE EXISTING
WITHIN THE UNITED STATES, IMMUNE
TO MARKET FORCES AND COMMON
SENSE AND YOU AND YOUR KIDS ARE
PAYING FOR THIS CRAP.
IF YOU ARE 23, YOU WON'T BE ABLE
TO AFFORD A HOME AND YOU WON'T
BE ABLE TO GET MARRIED.
WHAT A BARGAIN.
YOU ARE GETTING POORER AND
DUMBER ALL FOR THE SAME PRICE.
HOW STUPID CAN YOU GET?
GO TO COLLEGE AND FOR 37 GRAND,
YOU WILL FIND OUT.
>> Dana: MAYBE SMU IS THE
EXCEPTION?
>> Greg: THE MESSAGE I'M
TRYING TO GET TO THE COLLEGE
KIDS IS THAT IT'S A WASTE OF
TIME.
DROPOUT RIGHT NOW.
EVERYTHING WILL BE GREAT.
>> Dana: HOW ABOUT DON'T
LISTEN TO GREG YET BUT BE AWARE.
YOU SHOULD KNOW, THE COST.
WHAT IS THE BENEFIT, WHAT'S THE
VALUE YOU ARE GETTING?
WHAT ARE YOU PAYING FOR.
AND HOLD THOSE ADMINISTRATORS TO
TASK.
>> Greg: TO BE FAIR, SMU IS A
GREAT SCHOOL.
JESSE, THESE KIDS ARE GOING TO
BE PAYING FOR FOUR YEARS OF
NOTHING FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES.
>> Jesse: ON THE FARM -- IF
I'M A FATHER PAYING 60 GRAND FOR
MY KID TO GET BRAINWASHED, I
WOULD RATHER HAVE THEM WATCH CNN
WOULD RATHER HAVE THEM WATCH CNF
WOULD RATHER HAVE THEM WATCH CNR
FREE.
REMEMBER THE CRAZY LEFT-WING
PROFESSOR IN COLORADO, HE SAID
PEOPLE ON 9/11 DESERVED TO DIE,
AND IT TOOK THAT UNIVERSITY LIKE
TEN YEARS TO BOOT HIM OUT
BECAUSE HE HAD TENURE.
I WAS JUST AT CORNELL ASKING WHY
IS CORNELL SO LIBERALLY BIASED,
AND THEY KICKED ME OUT.
IT'S TOTALLY BACKWARDS.
IT IS SNOWFLAKE CITY.
THEY NEED SAFE SPACES TO DO
ANYTHING ANYMORE.
IF WE EVER FIGHT A REAL WAR,
WHO'S GOING TO FIGHT IT, NOT
THESE GUYS.
THEY BEAT THESE GUYS.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU HAVE TO
ADMIT 12-1 IS GROUPTHINK.
>> Juan: I THINK WHAT WE NEED
FOR AFFIRMATIVE ACTION IS --
UNDERACHIEVERS.
I DISAGREE WITH YOU BECAUSE I
THINK PARENTS AND STUDENTS ARE
PAYING FOR HIGH-LEVEL EDUCATION.
THEY BELIEVE IN EDUCATION.
THEY BELIEVE IN THE BENEFITS OF
IT, AND IF YOU GO TO THE BOOKS,
GO TO THE NUMBERS.
COLLEGE GRADUATES MAKE MORE.
>> Dana: OVER THEIR LIVES.
>> Greg: YEAH, BUT IT'S NOT
WORTH IT.
>> Dana: THEY ARE GOING TO BE
LATE BUYING A HOME AT A SECOND
CAR THAT THEY WILL ALSO HAVE ALL
THE DEBT THAT THE BABY BOOMERS
AND GENERATION X IS PUTTING ON
THEM.
>> Juan: WOULD YOU RATHER YOUR
KID GO TO COLLEGE OR NOT?
>> Greg: NO.
PETER THIEL HAS A GREAT IDEA,
$100,000 GRANTS.
START A BUSINESS INSTEAD OF
GOING TO COLLEGE.
IT'S BETTER TO LEARN TO OPEN A
BUSINESS.
>> Lawrence: I COVER THIS
EVERY DAY.
SMU, LOVE YOU GUYS.
WE PULLED REPORTS FROM SMU OVER
2017 TO 2018.
65,000 WENT TO DEMOCRAT
ORGANIZATIONS.
>> Juan: FINANCIAL
CONTRIBUTIONS?
>> Lawrence: FACULTY,
ADMINISTRATORS, PROFESSORS ON
THE COLLEGE CAMPUS.
IF THEY ARE GIVING FOR THE
DEMOCRATS 100% OF THE DONATIONS
FROM A 65% --
IF THEY ARE GIVING TO DEMOCRATS,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THEY ARE
TEACHING THE STUDENTS?
>> Juan: I THINK THEY BETTER
BE TEACHING ACADEMICS.
>> Jesse: WHEN I WAS AT
HARVARD DOING A WATTERS' WORLD
PACKAGE, I ASKED TO GROW SLOWLY
THINK ABOUT FAST AND FURIOUS.
THEY SAID, THE MOVIE?
THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW.
>> Lawrence: MEANWHILE.
>> Juan: NOT EXPOSED TO
RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACIES.
SAN DIEGO STATE.
>> Lawrence: DO WE WANT TO BE
TEACHING OUR STUDENTS?
>> Juan: YOU DON'T THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO TEACH ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS?
>> Lawrence: TO IMPEACH
DONALD TRUMP?
>> Juan: NO.
>> Lawrence: IT'S NOT A
HEADLINE.
IT'S A COURSE.
>> Juan: IT'S THE TITLE OF THE
COURSE.
ARE YOU A SNOWFLAKE?
ARE YOU SO WORRIED?
I AM SAYING TEACH.
>> Lawrence: BOTH SIDES.
>> Juan: THEY DO.
>> Juan: IT'S A ANTI-TRUMP
COURSE.
>> Juan: IF YOU ARE TEACHING